protect your bubble calm proud sponsors
of swipe on Sky News your ting swipe
coming up on the show this week the
video games exclusive we go behind the
scenes at some of the keys biggest
blockbuster games makers bringing Arkham
Knight to lights power designers on the
latest Batman titles perfects the
characters and the best game to buy now
and to look forward to check out our
reviewers take on the summers hottest
releases have you ever wondered how
big-budget video games are actually made
this week we decided to find out we've
been given access to two major studios
this is Rocksteady in London where they
make be hugely successful Batman Arkham
trilogy more on that in just a moment
but first Stu has been - TT games to
meet the team behind the much-loved Lego
series making a big-budget video game
takes a lot of work although it might
look like play the people at TT games
have a dedication to Lego each digital
brick or piece you see in these games
has to work in the real world this team
has given the Lego treatment to films
like Star Wars and Indiana Jones
now it's Jurassic park's turn we take
the film footage of the vehicle we then
use the block our model and build the
out Lego using our extensive library so
we've got you know three thousand parts
to choose from trying to get the essence
of the vehicle of course using the t-rex
is referenced and it's not just vehicles
the character John Hammond walked with a
limp throughout the first film and how
the cane one of the animators decided
that for his idol instead of him just
standing around leaning on his cane he'd
actually do almost a little bit of a
show tap-dance it's things like that we
can play on and almost flip the
character on its head with with what
they're supposed to be like and what
they're actually like in a Lego game
quirky humor is a big part of this
series identity the jokes are partly in
fired by the film's on which they're
based and partly the work of the writers
one of the things you're noticing in the
game is that no one dies you know in the
film obviously yeah quite a high body
camp in our version they all somehow
survive so yeah always incredibly
conscious that these are played by
families and children over at Rocksteady
Studios its launch week for their latest
game Arkham Knight problems with the PC
version of the game aside the team is
hoping the third title in its Batman
trilogy can match the success of the
first two like the lego games this
franchise also has a unique identity a
huge part of that is the sound like this
music which players can hear in what's
called predator mode when Batman is
stalking the bad guys well like more
layers of intensity to this music so
we've added a synth synth line there
this percussion there and Mar since
quiet the Wellness the early built it up
isn't it and then the brass and multiple
cushion
and then of course if if you go and hide
will come smoothly back to the beginning
for slightly common yeah and then at
that point branch somewhere else the
voice actors add another dimension the
only people left on the streets of the
sort that enjoy the chaos scum criminals
and worse do you really think scarecrows
crazy enough to breaking bad's Jonathan
banks joins the cast as Commissioner
Gordon Alfred and Kevin Conroy
once again voices The Dark Knight this
part of the trilogy is a much more
psychological challenge for Batman
he's being ripped apart and he's
fighting for his identity for me as an
actor it was a blast to get to flex
those muscles Arkham Knights a huge game
it's really the epic conclusion of
everything that we've learned from
Arkham Asylum and Arkham City all of
those learnings eight and a half years
of learnings three and a half years of
development building this epic
conclusion to the Arkham story another
important element of making the Batman
Arkham series is motion capture which
they do right here on site at Rocksteady
Gemma's been finding out more about that
and has even put on a superhero suit
kind of
okay that certainly feels snug are these
motion capture suits meant to be this
type they are actually so the markers
they exceed that around your body get
picked up by the 44 cameras in this room
of which gets fit for a super computer
and then out onto a skeleton that we see
live on the screen fantastic pretty cool
right
copying my every move so these suits are
what the models wear when you're
designing how the characters are going
to move in the game yeah that's right so
we have the internal animators that come
in
suit up and then we direct them for a
number of scenes the staff that work
here can come right poses Riddler yeah
that's right penguin Harley you name it
and what kind of direction do you have
to give them it could be anything from
like there could be a choreographed
fight scene or it could be something
else mundane as drinking a glass or the
kid we bought a whole bunch of weapons
we can use so people can you fit in a
fight scene at once we capture popping
at the same time in this room it's
pretty impressive for a small little
room that we go and how long would she
like that go on for sure it's not know
me about half a day and we've done about
300 shoots but I can light alone 300
sheets full for the one game that's
right yeah what character ain't any mean
to you today I'll tell you in through
the bat uh-huh check it out that's
amazing do I do I look realistic I mean
well you definitely realistic I don't
know if you cut the part maybe the work
needs to be a bit more wood purpose
maybe just hold your breath 10 you got
those muscles everywhere just pounding
along and you step more purpose
I suppose it shows you can turn pretty
much anyone is about it does yeah I mean
even someone as small frame as yourself
on to such a large man like the bats
okay so how else would you direct me so
with that man obviously and so maybe we
should try one of your best punches
maybe
ah much more comfortable so if you
didn't already you now know a heck of a
lot about Batman Arkham Knight and Lego
Jurassic world how do they compare to
some of the big titles also release this
summer here's Holly
so the arkham knight is the third in
Rocksteady's Arkham series of games and
it is a fantastic it's just a wonderful
open-world it's full of detail all
handcrafted Gotham looks absolutely
beautiful and then right in kind of
shimmering in the rain of course there's
the classic combat system that they
really kind of they started in Salem and
they've really perfected it there are
multiple ways you can take down enemies
so many gadgets that you can use so
they're finally introduced the Batmobile
in this game and there are two different
modes of it there's the fast racing mode
and kind of tank mode and it can feel a
little bit on Batman like using the tank
loader kind of blasting away through
there can be a little bit fiddly having
to use that and it kind of stealth mode
that they have however it is a lot of
fun and overall it is a crowning jewel
and in the Arkham series which is
probably one of the best superhero video
game series
Lego Jurassic world from TT games is the
usual puzzle platforming adventure
format that we've come to expect from
lego games it may not be the best Lego
game out there but it is fun and it's
very fast-paced there are five stages
fitted into the four movies and they're
full of charm as with any other Lego
game there are over a hundred playable
characters so fountain movies will
really love seeing their favorite
characters brought to life in the kind
of Lego fashion the overworld and the
fast travel orbit messy are not great
however fans the series fans the movies
will love seeing the kind of usual
slapstick comic style of the lego games
brought to the Jurassic Park series
so Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain
by Kojima Productions is promising to be
a new take on the open world genre it's
only in the preview stage the moment
nobody's played the full game yet it's
out in September although it doesn't
seem like a huge world at first it's
packed of such detail and you can
interactive almost anything it seems to
be a lot to the gameplay also this time
around the AI has been enormous ly
improved they're very unpredictable
which means that staying out of sight
becomes a real task however in this game
unlike the previous Metal Gear Solid
games getting into combat isn't seen as
much of a last resort although the focus
is very much in being stealthy and being
silent it's not seen as something that's
bad this time it's something that's part
of the game rather than you know you
failed that mission also with the added
addition of the mother base and
companions there seems to be a huge
variety of to the gameplay so in the
preview options so far there seems to be
that Kojima is bringing all of his
promises and more to this game so it's
definitely wanting
well that's it checkouts Kony's the iPad
and mobile for some bonus features from
this week's show I'll see you next time
bye bye
protect your bubble comm proud sponsors
of swipe on Sky News